[Music]
hello everyone and welcome I know you
didn't expect me but now I'm here now
I'm here and we are going to talk about
stomping the
scandy yes that's the time of the year
we bash the
Scandinavian now there's a reason we
want to beat that opening because it's
unsound remember those words
unsound now many people are chasing
their candidate spots we're going to
chase the lady around that'll be the
whole goal of this lecture but before we
do we're going to start up with a couple
of warmup puzzles now they come from
different places says you may still
notice these names this one is from a
match between Gallagher and
Williams and yes it's that Williams the
Simon
Williams however unlucky for the side
playing Black it is indeed white to move
and Crush Black's
defenses now I give these puzzles so you
learn the good habit of having a better
Pawn structure that's actually one of
the reasons why white is in favor in
this position and has a beautiful shot
because black structure is uneven and
that whole G file is a
nuisance so your goal will be to find a
way to crash through in this position
I didn't expect you but I'm here because
you are
perfect
perfect well you can quite ask anything
from the commentators I'm going to
commentate on your efforts on this very
nice puzzle over here Queen H5 is a
checkmating idea however I would
suspect that Williams would spot your
threat and
defend let's go Rook H7 you go here I go
here and for
now tight defense so one of the things
is key whenever you're attacking and
it'll be an important topic during those
Scandinavian games is that you got to
have a Swift attack going before they
can somehow find a defense so you got to
go all in before they can just Mand the
pain Bishop
takes well in that case I may actually
just run
away first you've got to lose your
opponent into the trap in this
position you got to First lure the
opponent where they don't want to
be Knight E4 brings a piece but it
doesn't really do too much I can just go
Rook A7 I do see you've got this neat
little
trick and it's actually well worth
remembering however it's not uh forcing
white can't force black to
capture Queen G for check indeed so
these are actually the hardest moves
whenever you're trying to play a
combination or a tactic you want to
create a scenario where your opponent's
pieces are awkwardly
placed Queen G4 of course is forcing the
black king to go here if you go King F7
I may just pick the pawn up so King
h8 so so we're sort of doing something
that you don't see in
Puzzles we got the pruzzo up on the
board we kind of made the first
preparator Preparatory steps out there
to
succeed so we already got the G file
under
control
just need another gangster piece to join
the
party that
is
daruk the gangster piece over
there right now there's many obstacles
in the way and therefore all all these
high class players go
woohoo well then we just give it away
willy-nilly so Billy can join the
party so boom we take this now if they
capture then we go Rook D3 and this is
actually a typical pattern also welcome
welcome typical pattern in this type of
position
you do the Rover just to move
over and that works especially because
the queen is there to block off any
threats by the bishop so of course you
can't x-ray through the queen and this
is Checkmate so there's a little bit of
Agony in the position black does go Rook
A7 but let's continue on of course we
are getting close to winning
however you still have to win the one
game so the question is what are we
going to do with that Bishop disclaimer
if you can't just leave it there because
if I move the Rook they capture it and
then we don't even have Checkmate
because the Rook will be a good defender
on the
H5 the question is where to put the
bishop
G6 of course you put the bishop here
because in your mind's eye you're sort
of thinking this King might want to rush
towards the Pawns in fact a pawn
structure or a pawn Shield that you have
in front of the king can be something
that is moved even if the king would
make it to E7 V would consider that safe
despite them not being the classical
Pawn Shield you're used to so it doesn't
really matter where you have the pawn
Shield as long as in its front of your
king we can consider it safe so Bishop
G6 Rook G7 so black here is trying to
use his pieces as
Shields however that will not stop us
should never stop us from going full
aggro how can we go full aggro mode in
this
position
feel free to Air your
thoughts don't be
shy it's not going to help your
game maybe it does but not in this
case
yeah you can give a
check and I move my
king mhm so he did in a different move
order but essentially does the same
thing the reason Gallagher actually
didn't give the
check um the king in fact on h8 isn't
doing that particularly well so if your
opponent's pieces are awkward you you
should let them nudge you to force them
uh this King actually wants to go this
way so if we don't have to we shouldn't
be giving the check so he goes Rook D3
King
G8 Rook Rook G3 Queen
B7 Queen H5 rook d8 and here comes the
final touch and after that it
immediately collapses and black
resigns
simple but effective
move Rook H3 of course the king moves to
f8 if I go Rook
G8 so here
here and
GG's exactly it's Checkmate
so in many cases we want to waiter
around a little bit so our opponent
actually wastes time moving their
awkward piece all right next puzzle
we've got the Evergreen
game by
hoian and um it is white to move and I
would want to start out
with kind of thinking of the position
cuz we always solve puzzles with oh boom
boom boom I win when in
fact just if you understand what's
happening in the position will give you
a hint of the direction you should be
taking so my first question would be who
has a safer
King
does she have a safer king or does the
opponent have a safer
King
really
okay that's a good point there's not
many pieces around the king and her
kingie
are that's true
but there is some objective metrics you
can use whenever you look at an
attacking
position and that is I'm going to ask
Sarah what is the objective
metric we look for when we talk about
King
safety are tring say Pawn Shield Pawn
Shields of course so in this case black
has Pawns in front of that King ours is
a little bit out in the open so we
sometimes have this feeling that okay um
you know we on The Winning Side so we
ought to be safe however objectively
this king is it's a little dodgy on B2
cuz it can run into plenty of
checks
now in order to win this game we got to
smoke that King out of
there because there's just too many
pawns shielding
it and here we got to think of different
ways we could do it now there's a reason
I talk about King safety the reason I
mention King
safety there's a level of urgency for
black the level of UR mergency is low
because the king is relatively safe our
King is out and about in the open so
time is not really on our
side so Rook h8 King takes h8 Rook H1 is
a beautiful donation for the black cause
there it's fancy it's nice but white
will not be too happy with
you so what I do in in this case is I
list a couple of moves now Rook aade is
a little bit out there however is an
idea sometimes random looking moves work
it's not the case this time around
however it's still would think of some
attacking moves I saw saw Rook H3 being
an idea preparing to
double and that's definitely on the
agenda any other move
that may make
sense G4 of course and knowing that we
got no time clock is ticking we we got
to go g exactly it does go with Tempo we
wi Time by attacking the
lady chasing the lady the key sentence
and the key word chasing the lady
you'll see why it's so
important so Queen
F7 Queen H2 you're going in there it's
also a Checkmate Queen
C7 and this is the moment you sort of
have to wonder okay do I have a strong
plan as
white and will I get checkmated or
Perpetual which is a bit more realistic
because black only has one Queen roaming
around the spirit of my suggestion was
that the AG file is weak that's correct
the age file is indeed weak and we're
trying to take advantage of
that speak up I know you can't hold it
in I like Bishop D okay because it defs
the
only
draws I feel it's a
flavor okay flavorful win Bishop d8 very
creative and indeed of course if Bishop
d8 Rook takes you could check and just
pick up stuff yeah I don't think it
works MH I wanted to MH no Bishop d8 is
definitely an option
however you
can actually have an easier route
simpler route to Victory Bishop di is
very creative and
sometimes these Solutions are needed uh
sometimes there's no other way but to
play Fancy moves but for some reason
they say just just keep it
simple if you
can and in this case I think it is
definitely an option now I know I scared
most of you because I'm a scary grandmas
and I said
Perpetual but you don't have to trust me
like
that it may not be a
Perpetual it may just be a
check I know I'm
scary people call me the scary
grandm I don't know who they are but
sometimes they
do all right so one of the key things
you can look at in this position is your
opponent's plans and that's sort of
undervalued what is black about to do
here a give a check on B6
and then you have to kind of wonder how
we're going to
respond and in this a sense we're going
to project the future the future plans
of our opponent which actually might be
crucial
here so check where would we go
then
well we go King to A1
right preferably if you can you want to
hide behind the pawn and make sure your
king is safe in that
case so you know that in that case well
Queen D4 we just capture that and then
we should have done no Perpetual there's
just a check that's it nothing else now
we can look at that ways we can try to
Checkmate black so first you certain
that there's no danger on your K we did
just
that
so you always have to look for
weaknesses in your opponent's position
not only in tactics do you have to look
for pieces pawns that are unprotected
but in general positions like this I
mean General I guess is not the right
word but in a wild position like this as
well so what would be a potential Target
here
well it's either E6 or
G6 it's fairly difficult to overwhelm
the E6 Pawn especially as we know that
Queen B6 check is going to
happen however
that's not the case with the G6
Pawn so how can we pile up on the G
pom
any
yeah uhhuh of course simple as that
Queen
H7 Rook H6 and this looks very
awkward and um you might be going hey
now I know this method be very careful
your queen can very easily get trapped I
mean conveniently the Knight is blocking
this but you know if I would make couple
of
moves there could be Rook h8 ideas so
you should know that your queen can get
into danger if you're not careful but in
this case black is completely under
developed and her attack Yan's attack is
about to break through so black does the
right thing trying to get some play
getting closer to the
king now if it would be Black's move
black would go start checking around and
maybe Nick a
draw but there's no Nicks here so we may
as well have time to crash on through
before they start checking
us it is a direct sequence and of course
uhan the legend she is she found it and
you guys over here will become Legends
yourself if you find it only if you find
it
Legends the Legends yes alwaysed this
see Ben Simon is becoming a legend right
now he deserved to be a legend already
but this will be the crowning
moment no pressure no
pressure
we should start checking them to annoy
them yes but the goal of the game is to
check and
mate not to check check check for that
game there's Tic Tac
Toe all right I'm ready to become a
legend all right Ben Simon is about to
become a legend all right I say queen G6
that is correct G
and then the Rook all the way down
oh close no they
capture yeah yeah yeah but then but then
uh the other Rook to H1 right the King
goes
back and King tries to run and hide G
Queen
G6
um
choose choose
brutality
brutality by
Sarah that is a legendary
Checkmate quite
brutal every piece is being used and
this my friend and enemies
especially is a double Checkmate a
rarity a rarity not something you see
every day hyper
clap for
Sarah and everyone who found
it and of course youa all right so we've
got all these puzzles out of the way out
of our system
and we're
going
for stomping the
scandy so E4 D5 takes
takes this is a game between Brodsky and
gamova gamova is a legendary Grandmaster
she's also a legend of a game of the
game brki mial probably you haven't
heard of not to be confused with David
Bry um also a very strong player
however he did not play gamova now the
first question you have to ask
yourself when you're facing the
Scandinavian what type of mistakes did
Black already
make this is an opening where on move to
you can go shake your head and point out
that Queen is doing something naughty
that she ought to not
do what's the reason that Queen is not
supposed to be
there yeah it's going to actually be
chased around the whole board now in
fact there is a rule
in this case for the Queens the early
morning rule of
chess if it is move 7 it's kind of like
7 a.m. in the morning on the chessboard
would you wake up the queen I don't
think you want to risk your
life move eight that's 8:00 a.m. that's
okay now look at the chessboard it's 2
a.m. in the
morning someone's going to
get it's going to get dirty real quick
there's no good news so what should we
do Chase it around and indeed Brodsky
goes Knight
C3
D4 Knight F6 Knight F3 okay so the
reason this whole variation is
favorable for white because you can
always gain time on the queen so we
should actually think of
ways we could harass that poor
lady it's just wrong I don't know why I
even had to say those things she doesn't
deserve that kind of
treatment
so how can we go after her majesty what
moves or potentially ways of going after
it there a couple of
ways of course we know Brodsky played
Knight F3 you can actually work with
that idea if you want
to indeed Bishop to D2 is a typal iCal
idea you are kind of eyeing the queen
and there often will be jumps of the
Knight especially after something like
Bishop C4 and they have Knight D5 ideas
one of the typical ways even though not
played in these games is this one there
is Knight to D5 and immediately
everything is sort of collapsing because
the queen can't pret can't protect this
Pawn on C7 Queen has to leave and then
you just lose
stuff so Bishop D2 is one way of trying
to inconvenience the queen what else
especially as we know the Knight f move
was played there's one other method and
it's actually quite a good
one indeed C Smith that is correct in
fact we're going to get
there we are going to get Gambit
mode so where do you think this Knight
is headed to it's heading it's heading
somewhere
where is it heading people where is it
heading
E5 and what's the
idea is that the Final
Destination
no indeed the Knight wants to hop to C4
now the thing is with the scandy is that
often times the fact that you have a
threat forces them to make
concessions so C6 Knight to E5 and this
is sort of a double double ax clam kind
of move now it's kind of difficult to
say it right now that it's a double ax
clam kind of move but I would give it a
double xlam for two reasons you put it
in the center and you put pressure on
the
queen so it's a multi-purpose move one
of the famous sayings if a move has dual
purposes it can't be bad unless you
plunder a queen
but that's a purpose in
itself don't do it if you if you can't
avoid it so black plays the weird
looking Bishop to
E6 and I mean if you ask me this is a
win we forc our opponent to put the
bishop on a weird spot
so Bishop D3 Knight D7 takes takes
castles and look at what transpired so
far black didn't develop too much
right so black has been wasting a lot of
moves that the queen and been trying to
catch up what Ry
doing while they did that we got the
center we got some pieces out and we're
castled and what comes next after
that we go King
hunting so Bishop G4 Knight D2 We don't
mind the trade then we would just get
the bishop
Paar long castles now long Castle is
already a sign of
desperation because gamova here realized
that she's desperately behind
development however if you think about
it do you think long Castle is a good
move no why
not yeah so the king is already a little
bit Breezy over there so this
move is already Dody that means we're on
the right
track so goes F3 so so there's no pins
over here F3 otherwise is not such a
great move but in this case you just
want to shut this bishop off the game
Bishop H5 okay so far so
good now we
want to get our attack
Brewing you got to do
something
ship F4 okay it's a completely normal
move it's a decent move however don't
forget you're playing against this candy
the goal of white is
to bully the lady I mean is it well B4
is an idea but you don't necessarily
have to be so generous Sarah all the
time I get the be you get the Bea but
they get a pawn yaser would be really
unhappy with
you no donos be
greedy humiliate the scandy player
exactly be greedy don't give up the
pawn bishop D2 go Bishop D2 yeah Bishop
D2 is fine um
so if you're a structure like you like
structures a
lot which one is our potentially weakest
spot is
white D4
Pawn it's the D4
Pawn now how can we make sure it's
guarded
forever
C3 C3 that's exactly what we want now
you can go Bishop D2 but remember what I
said
earlier that um if your opponent's
pieces are
misplaced don't help them because if we
go Bishop D2 now they will shake your
hand and say thank you so much you're so
generous okay that's true but that's why
I would go either C3 you could also go
B4 and we'll see a game like that but
for now this is the more conservative
way of
playing you guys don't like broadsky's
way of playing all right all right
you'll see some cooler stuff soon enough
so
C3 E5
B4 case and point you can't take that
cuz I take back can't touch this queen
C7
B5 start rolling so one of the things
and that's why it's actually a lot of
fun to play against the Scandinavian
once you just nail the target you just
keep hitting the Target and it's over
that's it you just chase the queen
around and Boom Boom Boom game that's it
it's not that hard just keep that
pattern going boom boom boom game
over and preferably you chase the lady
around okay so
C5 and um you should
follow in the same vein in this position
this next move should come
naturally natural aggressive move that
chemel clutcher would
play I know you guys think I don't see
Chad I see
y'all so
behave
A4 that's too solid you're welcome to
the candidates but not it's not it's not
even mentioned in this ches not even
mentioned
come on don't be so
oldfashioned don't just give away pawns
we'll do that
later not now Queen A4 is fun and is
indeed fun and it is indeed played
indeed sap sa Cornell sap Queen A4
indeed is the move why is Queen A4 such
a fabulous little
move it's simple chess is a simple game
everyone looks at me like I'm saying
something out of this world no simple it
does two things yes two things what two
things
yeah this x-ray
thingy yeah so our lady gets out of
trouble's way and harms way and we also
messing around with the
Aon so what you really you want to
do is just not give a breather for your
opponent because in the scandy they
don't have time they're losing a lot of
time with the queen moves so actually
attacking makes a ton of
sense so Bishop G6 also not quite the
best move takes takes and
here bronsky makes a move that looks
weird weird but it's actually quite
brilliant No Cap
brilliant if anyone will suggest the
pawn capture I'll know you're yaser in
Disguise but disclaimer that's not the
move yeah Adam D takes
E5
so the thing is you do want to open up
the position real quick because black is
just like having a full garage sale over
there they're not participating at all
they're not even close by and they're
not going to help out so D takes Queen
takes E5 and here probably gamova
thought hey I got a double
attack what you GNA do Mr Grandmaster
what you going to
do and you know how Grand Masters are
they're sneaky they come up with the
most spectacular and nice
ideas
Alo chamel clutcher is suggesting we ban
both of those openings it's very good
idea we actually need to have more of
those tournaments where you can ban
certain openings before the game you put
in an
envelope and then you open it up and
those two openings cannot be played that
event anti- themematic exactly thank you
Sarah that's
EXA that's a good name for it we're
going to pretend that one we're going to
do it we must do that one I think that's
going to be amazing Ben Simon I hope is
on
board hopefully he's not on board
tragedy
anyways you got to burn burn them
bridges down over here because this has
to become a Bridge Burner
go on go on I'm listening
I'm yes
and something something you get
checkmated that's what happens in the
scandy for black you get M and uh often
times you'd be like well there's the
defense what defense where are your
Defenders well everyone's chilling in
hati somewhere doing nothing and if you
go here boom and I say goodbye to that
chilling rook and doesn't even see it
coming so mean this game is so
mean so black goes Knight D5 is tricky
move but now white again plays a pretty
beautiful
one so we always enticed to play
aggressively
however you should think about Escape
Routes for the defense that's one of the
important things whenever you're in
attack mode look for potential ways for
your opponent to try to escape where
would this king would love to
go which Square I mean wouldn't love to
but that's that's the only option she's
got yeah would love to somehow Walt over
to the other
side so here brony's next move is
silence but
deadly which
one okay why did you choose the a
rock the
so I know you asking what's the
difference what does it matter it always
matters in fact you had a fantastic
point
there the king is safe if you have a
rook next to it and The Rook can
sometimes
block so it just make sense to involve
Alfred who was not doing particularly
much
so and also is pretty powerful here
because you can take this I check you
here and it is
Checkmate so I'm actually taking away
all those squares and now Queen A8 Rook
takes D5 will become really powerful now
everything crumbles in this case green
takes F1 it's clearly a des sign of
desperation takes check takes here King
E2 Rook
D5 okay so once you start attacking you
should never
stop should never stop even if you
checkmated you say we want to we want to
attack I'm I kid I kid but
here your attack is sort of half
finished still have to go for
it especially when your opponent's king
is uh so
Breezy you want to force matters many of
you are fixated on pushing the B Pawn
and I understand it looks cool but black
can't choose whatever move they'd like
in that
case Queen a check of course King
C7 they can't really move the bishop
because the Rook will drop after the
trade King B6 and here why just go
C4 Rook D4 and this next move is pretty
so don't want to spoil it it just
looks aesthetically pleasing it looks
strange but it just looks
cool Bishop B8 indeed Bishop B8 and even
though it looks extremely funny as you
put your pieces absolutely where they
don't belong but Queen A7 is Checkmate
and the game is is all about
checkmating takes and it
just actually makes life harder Queen A7
is mating again so she took on A4 and
after that she
resigned so what we learned from this
game I believe is that you want to gain
time you always want to improve your
position but try to gain time on the
queen so let's look at a couple more of
the classics this is Vish Anand against
joier Luchi is not as well known these
days however he was helping Vladimir
kramnick in many of his world
championship matches so let's get in
here Knight C3 D4 Knight F6 Knight F3 C6
now we already
know um what what type of ideas we
should be playing for he goes Bishop C4
which is of course a very natural move
and it's also a very good idea in
conjunction with Bishop D2 Bishop F5 and
now you have a specific idea here for
white is very powerful it's very very
similar to what we've seen in the
previous game however the twist than a
different
concept we go Knight E5 obviously E6 and
here actually vishy shows a pattern that
is very much worth remembering in fact
in fact in many cases the way to refute
Black's
concept this is a key
idea if you know
this you can't avoid being successful
just can't do it it's like that's it
you'll be successful with this trick
this is the ultimate
trick especially in the scandy
G4 let's roll Bishop G6 but
G4 is good because we've got this extra
move well poers might hate the London
but they love this simple
trick
and I mean they've got their priorities
right if you said
G4 you better go
H4 and this is actually a typical idea
and you may actually be able to use this
trick in many different openings that
are not even just E4
systems the point is we like to trap
this bishop if the pawn ever moves we
take here and it's game over because all
these pawns are just going to fall like
flies so black has to move Knight D7 and
then we can chase the bishop around
Bishop E4 Rook H3 and Rook H3 is a
unique idea by Vish Anand and it's just
brilliant because instead of closing off
files he's
involving his rook in the game Black
Goes Bishop G2 and this she finds the
weirdest
spot on the board however it's
completely logical that's how good vishy
is it looks weird yet it's
amazing well the bishop usually wants to
stay away from the white pieces that's
why originally black went to
G6 so where should we put that Rook just
use that simple logic that we always do
the principles of
chess what would
G3 so in
principle where do Rooks
belong uhhuh huh exactly open files so
we go Rook to E3 now this looks fairly
clumsy and it is but look at clumsy is
the bishop on G2 is a little
awkward so awkward for awkward and
that's actually a weird trade that we
have in chess if your opponent makes a
weird move you are entitled by the
Constitution in chess to play awkward
move moves
yourself remember your chest rights
people remember your chest
rights okay we've got that out of our
system even though though The Rook looks
funny this bishop on G2 is
funnier so Knight B6 Bishop D3 Knight D5
and
here vishy plays the astounding f three
move he says take my Rook if you want to
I don't care because your Bishop is
getting mummified over here and my king
is just going to eat it for
breakfast oo it sounds creepy but it's
true the king is going to eat that and
gble that Bishop
up so he goes Bishop B4 King F2 so even
though you lose the Rook you get two
pieces which is in favor for the white
side Bishop takes B takes yeah black did
fenet the bishop or probably
misunderstood the
concept so Queen takes C3 Rook B1 Queen
takes D4 Rook takes B7 so we can't quite
take here because they take on E3 so
we've got this weird situation going on
Rook d8
H6 G DH and here white actually plays a
spectacular move in this position a
spectacular
one and also practically a
clincher no this was a chess game Vian
Believe It or
Not top five alltime best of
Chess no how to play this game this was
no
preparation and if we go all in with the
queen
sack it's a rare Bishop win and a bishop
checkmate
Bishop
G6 funny thing is takes I take here here
and now you got plenty of Glorious Maids
but there's one that's the prettiest
right Bishop
takes
mate that is indeed hot if something's
hot on the chessboard this is
it it's a hottie a hot
one it's a beautiful one
unfortunately black decided to avoid
that and just lost
simply with these trades and the bishop
got trapped but I mean that other one is
kind of beautiful all right but last but
not least you were
like you're showing us all these soft
lines be want blood all right people you
wanted it here's the game between Hikaru
and
fua now as we know there's many people
trying to get the coveted candidate spot
look out for new rules they're
coming but here's a game a final game
and everyone was clamoring for this move
everyone was like you show us the
appropriate right way of playing but no
Gambit style come on show us a Gambit
style Sarah wants to say it with her
eyes tell me before before of
course and uh
fua takes the
challenge and to takes the pawn but
that's kind of the thing this will be
compensation because Hikaru has so many
pieces is just storming into the game so
it goes Rook B1 Queen D6 D4 Queen d8 now
look at that he went one two three four
five and we've got one two three pieces
out there black has none you're gonna
have fun people you're gonna have
fun so Knight F6 Okay so we've got one
thing out of the way we got some of the
pieces out what is there left for us to
do as white you're on the roll you're on
the roll but what comes
first king safety that's right you go KN
F3 E6
Castello El
Castello Bishop E7 now they're already
in
here we've got all of our pieces is out
however principles come
first Rook to E1 I mean you go Rook E1
after Knight E5 but hey Karu knows it
better C5 and here comes the beautiful
beautiful move it's not going to win yet
but it's the first step in the right
direction
black thinks that he's safe nahh he
ain't safe at
all D5 we go break it
open we getting closer to the king e
takes Knight takes Bishop E6 and black
is like ah safety safety that's what we
wanted and here comes
the beautiful beautiful shot by
hiar the vest spot yes the V Spot for a
reason
boom Knight takes
F7 and here black in fact resigned now
if you take here F Knight takes E7 and
everything crumbles I just take
everything but this is the line and even
though the game ended we got to find
this one so King
takes this next move is going to shock
you probably
not but it's quite
maatic rookie six exactly
boom another big shot King takes Knight
takes King takes
check King
E5 Queen
G3 King
D4 and it is white to move and Checkmate
in
two
it's quite
pretty funny thing about these cases
that development you know that doesn't
have to rest or take a backseat just
because you're trying to
Checkmate Bishop B2 I I take the
bishop and queen B3 mate so Bishop B2
check if the King goes back we'll see
the mate there King takes Queen B3 quite
a nice mate black has everyone back at
home the scandy lady is saying oh I I
did my journey I had fun not as much the
king on
C4 and it actually ends the same way
here on Queen
E5 so I really hope you enjoyed scandy
hunting over with me and hope you'll
have a fun time checkmating black in the
future thank you so
[Music]
much
w